[Musique]
bonjour tout mineur d'anjou antibes on
sait juste qu'on est immense et nous a
fait faux bon vieux c'était aussi parce
qu'elle est même parfois en single man
et vous fait nous parler du bourgailh
nos parents sont ici vraiment new baby g
si nous on dit c'est que vraiment sonné
un bar un poteau en bois fm et nous
parlera du problème nous placer dû faire
la fête nous pas là pour ça donc anti
cons c'est aussi pas tous et n'importe
manière partout dans le monde tous ont
conduit john woo double social au fil à
internet et à fort bagage mais mon
iphone ou pampa tire-bouchon la ville
aux mélodies puis les couper tous les
cinq minutes et les foules au duo label
un mot sur l'hygiène idoine pour les
patients le monde la révision est aussi
évident le blizzard ont le plus souvent
possible
mais ma mère nous pensons aussi aux
vieux barbu starpack a fait la fête et
nous si nous payons et puis lors du
conseil et ses valises à dominance local
loyaux c'est pourquoi pour peut-être
nous avons assaini cobla à ne pas voter
bayrou
alors maurice fausse bien vraiment été
boxeur mohamed ali ben mon bon à mes
gars disaient ça pas évident mérité beau
gazon messieurs six semaines au québec
visana pis force et bebo journée
[Musique]